said earlier about prayer we ask for
that
and the ongoing support that's needed
from our standpoint is to give support
in any area that's that's asked for on
the scene so again we thank you and from
this point forward we'll just continue
on with our mission and try to bring
some type of closure and resolution
thank you
I anticipate there will be another
briefing
at or before four o'clock
we will entertain two or three questions
at this moment before these gentlemen
have to go back to the scene to continue
their work
in this case yet yes we have identified
the suspect it's a 28 year old female
white uh actually a nashvillian or lives
in the Nashville area
we are have an ongoing investigation as
it pertains to her at this time a place
where she lived if you have offices
there we have yeah body armor what she
went body armor I can't say uh that far
into the investigation I I don't
remember seeing it but I can't say for
certain if she had body armor on or not
the church
from my initial findings is that at one
point she was a student at that school
but unsure what year all of that but
that's what I've been told so far
you're getting examined at this point
the investigations are still going going
at this point of federal Partners our
state Partners we're all looking into
that to see exactly this is uh still
fluid at the time but we're looking at
everything did anybody pull the fire
alarm
don't remember a fire alarm going out I
was told there was kids that evacuated
into a wood line they had the presence
of mind to do that and to go to a fire
hall uh once we arrived on scene we had
everyone move to First Baptist Church
Woodmont
and that way we could get parents and
children reunited and then ultimately
make the notification on the three kids
that's that's that was a door that was
entered uh all doors were locked to our
understanding and how exactly she got in
at this point it's still under
investigation there is a vehicle uh that
uh was nearby that gave us Clues as into
uh who she uh who she was and so but as
stated that investigation is still
ongoing did the school have a school
shooter protocol
they did have protocol to my
understanding uh we had unfortunately
three
um kids that would tragically hurt it
could have been far far worse
okay folks we'll be back again before
four o'clock
okay thank you
you're watching Sky News tonight it's
coming up to eight o'clock and we've
just been listening in on a press
conference there with police officers
and local officials in Nashville
Tennessee where there's been yet another
shooting at a school where three
children and three adults have been
killed police also kills the shooter who
has now been identified as a 28 year old
woman
believed to have been a former student
at this private school in Nashville they
ended there saying that it could have
been so much worse let's bring in our
U.S correspondent James Matthews who's
been listening in on that too
um James of course another horrific
shooting President Biden speaking
earlier calling on Congress to ban
assault weapons yet again
yes Simon and yes again America
structures shrugs its shoulders I
suppose calls for change but finds
itself in a situation where it's a
question of when not if
circumstances like these will be
repeated this particular shooting
happened just south of downtown
Nashville in the Concord school because
of the school's ties to the church there
was no police presence at the time it's
a school that teaches youngsters
preschool around four five up until 11
12 years old three youngsters were
killed they've not yet been identified
although their families have been told
and three adults as you say were also
killed it's unfolded this horror over 14
minutes at 10 13 in the morning police
were given the emergency call they sent
A Team into the building itself in the
first instance they cleared the first
story it was in the second story of the
building that they engaged with this
woman and that's where she was killed
and the shooting stopped she has been
identified as you say as a 28 year old
white woman who used to be they think a
student of this particular institution
she was identified with the help of
registration plates on a vehicle that
was found nearby so I want to assume she
traveled to the school in that
particular vehicle President Biden has
spoken in the past 20 minutes and as you
say he's labeled this sick and
heartbreaking in a short statement at
the White House and it could have been
far far worse as you heard during that
short news conference given the numbers
inside the building at that particular
time there are something like 200
students at the this particular school
and they were hastily diverted away from
trouble
the second that the shooting started so
as bad as it was it could have been much
worse but three children died
three adults were killed and others are
being treated in hospital for their
injuries
James Matthews for now thanks very much
indeed well we mentioned a response of
course from the White House James just
uh talking about President Biden's
statement there speaking in the last few
minutes so let's listen in on what he
had to say
okay
you know uh Ben and I have been doing
this our whole careers it seems
and uh
it's just uh it's sick you know we're
still Gathering the facts of what
happened and why
and we do know that as of now there are
a number of people who are not gonna did
not make it
including children
it's heartbreaking
the family's worst nightmare
and I want to commend the police who
responded incredibly swiftly within
minutes and the danger
we're monitoring the situation really
closely Ben as you know
and we have to do more to stop gun
violence
okay well uh as we've said in the last
uh 10 15 minutes sir just before we came
to the top of the hour there was a news
conference with the police officers who
arrived at the scene representing the
First Responders who talked us through
what happened let's listen in for you
once again
all right this is our second
briefing on this active shooter
situation speaking to you at this point
will be Nashville chief of police John
Drake
the director of the Tennessee Bureau of
Investigation David Rausch
Nashville District Attorney Glenn Funk
and then Nashville fire director Chief
William Swann
again this is the second briefing there
will be other briefings to be held here
in the same spot later this afternoon
we'll continue to brief
throughout the rest of the day Chief
Drake
uh first and foremost I want to say uh
thank you all for for being here on this
very unfortunate
situation uh my heart and prayers go out
to the families of the six people who
would tragically uh injured
what what I know at this point is at 10
13 today officers responded to a shots
fired call to Covenant School it's a
church school
uh officers immediately responded a team
of five immediately went in the school
went to where gunshots were being heard
and engaged the suspect
we have identified the suspect right now
attentively a 28 year old female white
we know the address of that person as
well and so we have some ongoing
investigations as to that
we have three adult victims
and we have three children who have been
identified and their families have been
contacted
right now I will refrain from saying the
ages other than to say
I was literally moved to tears to see
this and the kids as they were being
ushered out of the
building
uh I want to say thanks to all of our
partners
to the FBI to the ADF and other Federal
to the thp Tennessee Highway Patrol
the TBI
the district attorney and to the fire
department
who all came together and seamlessly
addressed this situation as quickly as
possible
I've already gotten a requests from the
national media about
a great response was still assessing
that as well but what I can say and what
I've said before is that whenever I hope
that we would never have this situation
that if we ever did we would not wait
we would immediately go in and we would
immediately engage the person
perpetrating this horrible crime
and so that's all I can say right now we
have David Ross director of the TBI who
will come after me to address his
portion and then we have others that
will say something as well so thank you
thank you
again I want to Echo what Chief has said
in reference to the great support and
the great teamwork that has been taking
place here and as well as sending our
heartfelt prayers uh to the to the
families to this community of these
victims now I know there'll be people
who want to criticize us for prayers but
that's the way we do that in the South
right we we believe in prayer and we
believe in the power of prayer and so
our prayers go out to these families
um
the role of the TBI in this
investigation is we have been asked by
General Funk to assist in the
officer-involved portion of this
incident so the incident where the
officers engaged the suspect we are
assisting the Metro investigation and
the reason we've got Metro doing the
primary investigation is because it was
a fluid scene so there wasn't a single
stop in the action and so as they
investigate the homicides
then we felt it was most appropriate for
them to continue that investigation but
we will assist as as in our role as an
independent oversight on the officer
involved situation and so that that will
be the role of TBI we too want to thank
all of our partners
it is special we've had this
conversation unfortunately too many
times in Tennessee and that is that you
wish you wouldn't have to do these types
of scenes but when you do you want to
have the working relationships that we
have in our law enforcement Community
here in Tennessee it is amazing and
we've all come together as one and
working very tirelessly and we'll
continue to work together to address
this situation uh it's a it's a horrible
senseless tragedy uh and and we will be
here uh working with our partners to get
through it and next I'd like to
introduce the district attorney general
for this area uh Glen Fung
yeah this is
the ultimate crime when school children
and caregivers are the victims of
senseless gun violence
can't say anything before first
expressed our concerns for the victims
and their families
and the extended
number of victims that are traumatized
by today's events
I came out on the scene today because
our
current operating procedure is that when
an officer is involved in a shooting
that the TPI comes out and I knew that
this was a unique case and I want to
make sure that everything was handled
appropriately director Roush was out
here almost at the exact same time I got
here and chief Drake had already been on
the scene for a while the three of us
met and talked about how the
investigation was going to be handled we
made a joint decision
affirming what the two law enforcement
leaders
how they wanted to proceed which was
that Metro was going to handle
the bulk of this but the TBI would
participate in a capacity to continue
with making sure that we have
transparency and everything and to make
sure that uh any backup that mnpd needs
in this continued investigation would be
provided
can't not stress enough how seamlessly
that worked to have a
conversation
in a decision to be made quickly and
appropriately as far as how the case was
going to be handled from here
hats off to Chief Drake and to director
Roush I also want to thank Chief Swann
and our federal Partners as well
well I cannot comment about the ongoing
nature of the investigation I'm really
impressed with the work that's being
done by law enforcement
yes uh good afternoon
first let me just say as everyone else
what a tragic day here in Nashville
so our hearts and our prayers do go out
to all the family members and also the
First Responders that that actually made
this call as always the fire department
and office of emergency management our
job is to support
and we were here at the beginning and
we'll be here until the end we just
asked that everyone again as it was said
earlier about prayer we asked for that
and the ongoing support that's needed
from our standpoint is to give support
in any area that's that's asked for on
the scene so again we thank you and from
this point forward we'll just continue
on with our mission and try to bring
some